OLIVER DARCIE, GOOD TO HAVE YOU
WITH US FROM NEW YORK.
>> THANK YOU
>>> WELL, THE CULTURE OF SILENCE
WITH COMPLETE, EVEN CRUEL
INDIFFERENCE.
THAT'S HOW AN EXPLOSIVE NEW
REPORT IS DESCRIBING THE
RESPONSE BY THE FRENCH CATHOLIC
CHURCH TO SEVEN DECADES OF
SEXUAL ABUSE.
THE RESULTS OF THE INVESTIGATION
FOUND MORE THAN 200,000 MINORS
WERE SEXUALLY EXPLOITED BY
FRENCH CATHOLIC CLERGY SINCE
1950.
THE NUMBER JUMPS TO 330,000 WHEN
YOU ADD NON-CLERGY MEMBERS.
THE HEAD OF THE COMMISSION THAT
ISSUED THE REPORT SAYS THAT
ABUSE IS STILL HAPPENING.
>> Translator: THESE NUMBERS OF
216,000 AND 330,000 ARE FAR MORE
THAN CONCERNING.
THEY'RE APPALLING AND MUST
ABSOLUTELY NOT REMAIN
UNANSWERED.
THEY REQUIRE VERY STRONG ACTION.
>> WELL, THE REPORT REVEALS THE
SCALE OF ABUSE IN FRANCE IS FAR
MORE SEVERE THAN PREVIOUSLY
THOUGHT.
CNN'S JIM BITTERMANN IS
FOLLOWING THE STORY AND JOINING
US NOW FROM PARIS.
JIM, NOT ONLY DID THE REPORT
FIND IT IS FAR MORE PERVASIVE,
FAR MORE SYSTEMATIC THAN
PREVIOUSLY THOUGHT, IT ALSO
FOUND THAT THE CHURCH HIERARCHY
REPEATEDLY SILENCED THE VICTIMS.
>> Reporter: THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS I THINK, LYNDA, MOST
PEOPLE WERE -- SEEMED TO BE AT
LEAST THE MOST APPALLED ABOUT,
WAS THE OVERALL INDIFFERENCE OF
THE CHURCH HIERARCHY FOR
SOMETHING THAT WENT ON FOR YEARS
AND MAY STILL BE GOING ON TODAY
ACCORDING TO THE COMMISSION'S
REPORT.
SO IT IS REALLY SOMETHING THAT
THEY HAVEN'T ACTED SOONER ON
THIS.
PROBABLY THE MOST DRAMATIC
MOMENT IN THIS PRESS CONFERENCE
CAME THIS MORNING FROM FRANCOIS
DEVOE, THE HEAD OF THE VICTIMS'
ASSOCIATION, AND IN A VERY FIRM
WAY HE SAID, SPACING OUT HIS
WORDS VERY CAREFULLY, HE SAID,
"YOU MUST PAY FOR THESE CRIMES,"
SPACING OUT EACH WORD.
HE SAID IT WILL BE IN THE
BILLIONS.
SO IT WAS PROBABLY A NEWS
CONFERENCE THAT PUT INTO
ABSOLUTE FACE-TO-FACE
RELATIONSHIP NOT ONLY THE
VICTIMS' ASSOCIATION BUT ALSO
THE HEADS OF THE CATHOLIC CHURCH
IN FRANCE.
HERE IS A BIT MORE OF WHAT DEVOE
HAD TO SAY.
>> Translator: WHAT YOU MUST
UNDERSTAND IS THAT YOU ARE A
DISGRACE TO HUMANITY.
YOU HAVE TRODDEN ALL OVER THE
NATURAL OBLIGATION TO DEFEND THE
RIGHT AND DIGNITY OF THESE
PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: SO DEVAUX SAID
THAT, AND THEN THE HEAD OF THE
CATHOLIC BISHOPS ASSOCIATION
RESPONDED WITH THIS.
HE SAID, TO THOSE VICTIMS OF
SUCH ACTS I EXPRESS MY SHAME, BY
DREAD AND MY DETERMINATION TO
ACT WITH THEM.
NOW, THAT MAY NOT BE ENOUGH
BECAUSE THE VICTIMS, AS DEVAUX
SAID, ARE LOOKING FOR PERHAPS
BILLIONS IN COMPENSATION,
SOMETHING THAT MAY BE A LITTLE
DIFFICULT FOR THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH IN FRANCE TO COME UP WITH
BECAUSE IT IS NOT IN THAT GREAT
FINANCIAL SHAPE.
BUT NONETHELESS, AFTER THIS
TESTIMONY TODAY I THINK THE
OVERWHELMING OPINION IS THAT
THEY'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING, AND
THIS IS PROBABLY -- THE NEWS
CONFERENCE WAS PROBABLY THE
START OF THAT.
THEY'RE ALSO GOING TO SEND OUT A
MESSAGE TO THE CHURCH, TO CHURCH
BELIEVERS ON SUNDAY.
THEY'RE GOING TO SEND OUT A
MESSAGE TO BE READ IN ALL
PULPITS AROUND FRANCE, BUT IT
WILL BE A BIG BLOW TO THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH MOVING FORWARD,
LYNDA.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
JIM BITTERMANN FOR US IN PARIS.
WE ARE GOING TO STAY ON THIS
STORY.
THANKS SO MUCH, JIM.
>>> IN RESPONSE TO THAT REPORT
POPE FRANCIS EXPRESSED GREAT
SORROW FOR SEXUAL ABUSE AND HE
PRAISED THEM FOR COMING FOR.
I WANT TO HAVE JOHN ALLEN JOIN
US LIVE FROM ROME FOR MORE ON
ALL OF THIS.
WE HEARD THE POPE EXPRESSING
SORROW AND SADNESS FOR THE
VICTIMS IN A STATEMENT FROM THE
VATICAN.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF HIS REACTION
SO FAR AND WHAT MORE CAN WE
EXPECT TO HEAR FROM THE POPE?
>> Reporter: LYNDA, FIRST OF ALL
IT IS STRIKING WE GOT A REACTION
AS QUICKLY AS WE DID.
IN THE PAST WHEN THESE NATIONAL
LEVEL REPORTS WERE ISSUED,
WHETHER TALKING ABOUT THE RYAN
REPORT IN IRELAND IN 2009, MORE
RECENTLY THE REPORT IN GERMANY,
THE VATICAN HAS NOT REACTED
IMMEDIATELY, TAKING THE POSITION
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING FOR THE
LOCAL BISHOPS TO HANDLE.
BUT I THINK WHAT THEY'VE LEARNED
ON THE BACK OF ALL OF THAT AND
THE BACKLASH THEY GOT WAS THAT
ANYTHING THAT SMACKS OF
INDIFFERENCE OR DELAY IS NOT
GOING TO GO DOWN WELL.
SO I THINK THE FIRST POINT IS
SIMPLY THAT THE POPE SPOKE.
SECONDLY, I THOUGHT IT WAS
STRIKING THAT AT THE END OF HIS
BRIEF STATEMENT HE SAID THAT HE
WAS PRAYING BOTH FOR JUSTICE AND
FOR HEALING.
NOW, USE OF THE WORD "JUSTICE"
IN THAT CONTEXT IS A REFERENCE
TO CRIMINAL PROSECUTION AND ALSO
CIVIL LAWSUITS.
IN THE PAST THERE'S BEEN HEAVY
CRITICISM OF THE CHURCH FOR NOT
COOPERATING WITH THOSE
INQUIRIES.
I THINK THIS WAS FRANCIS'S WAY
OF SAYING WE NEED TO TURN OVER A
NEW LEAF.
>> JOHN, YOU MENTIONED SOME OF
THE OTHER CASES THAT WE'VE SEEN
AROUND THE WORLD, AND I JUST
WANT TO GO THROUGH SOME OF THOSE
FOR OUR VIEWERS BECAUSE THIS
INVESTIGATION IN FRANCE
CERTAINLY FOLLOWS OTHER REPORTS
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES.
IF YOU LOOK AT AUSTRALIA, THE
2017 REPORT FOUND THAT 7% OF
AUSTRALIAN PRIESTS WERE ACCUSED
OF ABUSING CHILDREN BETWEEN 1950
TO 2015.
THEN IF YOU LOOK, OF COURSE, IN
GERMANY, A 2018 REPORT FOUND
THAT THE GERMAN CATHOLIC CHURCH
ADMITTED TO AT LEAST 3,677 CASES
OF CHILD SEX ABUSE BY CLERGY
BETWEEN 1946 AND 2014.
THEN, OF COURSE, ENGLAND AND
WALES, A 2020 REPORT FOUND
BETWEEN 1970 AND 2015 THE CHURCH
RECEIVED OVER 900 COMPLAINTS
INVOLVING MORE THAN 3,000 CASES
OF CHILD SEX ABUSE.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU, JOHN, DESPITE
THE NUMBERS, DESPITE THE REPORTS
WE'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS, VERY FEW PEOPLE HIGH UP
IN THE CHURCH HIERARCHY HAVE
REALLY FACED REPERCUSSIONS,
RIGHT?
>> Reporter: WELL, I MEAN IF YOU
MEAN CRIMINAL PROSECUTIONS, NO.
THE ONLY -- AT THE MOST SENIOR
LEVEL, CARDINAL, OF COURSE,
THEODORE McCARRICK, FORMER
CARDINAL, FORMER PRIEST IN THE
UNITED STATES IS CURRENTLY
UNDERGOING CRIMINAL PROSECUTION,
BUT THAT'S FOR ABUSE HE
ALLEGEDLY COMMITTED HIMSELF, NOT
FOR THE COVERUP OF IT ALL.
ON THE OTHER HAND, LOOK, I THINK
ONE THING THAT SHOULD NOT BE
LOST IN ALL OF THIS IS THIS NEW
REPORT IN FRANCE IS NOT THE
RESULT OF AN EXTERNAL
GOVERNMENTAL COMMISSION OR SOME
OTHER EXTERNAL AUTHORITY.
THIS WAS ACTUALLY COMMISSIONED
BY THE FRENCH BISHOPS.
SO THESE REVELATIONS, AS UGLY
AND STAGGERING AS THEY ARE, IS
SOMETHING THAT THE CHURCH IN
FRANCE HAS DECIDED TO BRING UPON
ITSELF AS, YOU KNOW, UNDER THE
HEADING OF THE ONLY WAY OUT IS
THROUGH.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT A
NATIONAL BISHOPS CONFERENCE
WOULD HAVE DONE UP UNTIL VERY
RECENTLY, AND THAT I SUPPOSE IS
SOME MEASURE OF SOME KIND OF
PROGRESS, LYNDA.